thing that is
now we are
starting to go on
space missions very frequently so as you
can see on my screen
nasa has already planned the artemis
mission that is the next human landing
mission on ma on moon
after the apollo missions
but unlike the apollo missions these
artemis missions are not going to be a
two-day affair
these astronauts are going to stay on
the surface of moon for months at least
six months
and
quite naturally the effects of this
extreme journey and this
settlement on the surface of moon is
going to have some effects on the body
of the astronauts
so
this is something which i am really
interested in looking into and
understanding more about the mechanisms
that govern these changes
also
beyond moon we are definitely going to
mars sometime maybe in the 2030s or the
2040s because as you all know this
person elon musk would be very
disappointed if we can't do that just
like he said in his quote
so
with starship
being ready at a very rapid speed
it looks very likely that human beings
would be traveling to mars
also another aspect of space travel
which has seen a huge boost in this year
itself is space tourism
with blue origin
and virgin galactic coming into the
picture of space travel and doing some
successful space tourist missions
you can understand that now more and
more people are going to be involved in
space flight travels
be it an astronaut or be it a civilian
so it is quite the high time
to look into the problems that is faced
by the astronauts who
go to space
some of these problems are already known
to us since the days of the ablomations
that is almost 50 years ago like bone
and muscle density loss that's the
reason why the astronauts aboard the
international space station have to
indulge in rigorous exercise daily to
maintain the bone and muscle density
otherwise they lose it
at a
much much rapid speed
definitely there's physical strain
fatigue but there are certain
molecular changes
as well
and those molecular consequences are not
visible to the naked eye you cannot see
the phenotypic changes at first but
those changes do occur like what dilara
was saying about the changes in the gut
microbiome and factors of space flight
like radiation and microgravity play a
big role in changing this cut microbiome
composition then there's risks for
cancer development because of certain
signaling pathways being altered
there can be reproductive system issues
neurodegenerative diseases immune
response changes metabolic changes and
who knows what else there are so many
more unexplored issues which you and me
can look into
in much more detail
so
one of the major landmarks in the study
of what happens to the human
body at a molecular level
was studied in the nasa's twin study
this was a boon to humanity because
we got
an unparalleled opportunity to study the
effects of space flight the various
factors like
as i said ionizing radiation
microgravity
atmospheric temperature atmospheric
pressure composition difference
and many more
onto identical twins
these served as the best
samples that you can get because
the molecules the genes everything is
same
so the kelly brothers
scott kelly and mark kelly were involved
in this experiment and scott kelly went
to space and spend over 300 days on the
international space station whereas mark
kelly stayed on earth serving as the
ground
sample subject
after scott kelly returned to earth
as sunalika mentioned in the
introductory part there were nine
different groups who were assigned
different omics
atomic studies
there were groups which focused on the
genomics the transcriptomics proteomics
metagenomics epigenomics
and there was one final group
whose duty was to integrate all the
omics and analyze the
cumulative effect on the genome of
scotch kelly and they were actually
looking into multi-omics
so at pine biotech we focus on all these
omics studies including multi-omics
and how we do it i will be showing you
in a while
but first let's talk about what were the
results what did we observe from the
twin study
so to begin with let's talk about
genomics
so
in scott kelly there was a noticeable
increase in telomere length which
was kind of
not expected because as we know that
telomeres
should be shortened and aging is a
problem of space flight but
quite interestingly during his mission
it increased but once he returned back
on earth it shortened drastically so
this sort of observation needs more
research and understanding similarly
talking about transcriptomics there were
various
gene pathways that were altered
various novel genes that were identified
to be affected by space flight
and
scientists are still looking into what
effects
does those alterations have on the
astronauts body
so there are
several other studies or several other
omics
results which we will talk in pretty
much detail in the program
where the we will talk about the nasa
strain study as a case study we will
take every amic
level and discuss in detail the results
the findings and the implications and
what can we do with these results in the
future how can we get involved
but
this is the time when we should mention
what
made this sort of research possible
so we are here dealing with ngs data on
next generation sequencing data
and that's how we can actually look into
the genome and the transcriptome
but these
genome sequencing was made possible by
oxford nanopore technologies min ion
which is a very small
sequencer
the size of a pen drive it can fit into
your pocket and this was taken aboard
the international space station and the
astronauts blood was drawn and sequenced
right there on the international space
station and this
technology has opened the door for a new
era of space omics which we are dealing
with in this program and also
in the upcoming
one month program
now i would give you some example of the
different omics studies
based on space flights one of them is
the transcriptomic analysis of mice
and these mice were subjected to
simulations of deep space exploration
for example if you would like to go on
mars
then simulating that kind of a travel
for a longer period of time
and to see what are the effects
on the transcriptome on the gene
expression of mice
was the focus of this research group
and they found various immune system
pathways and micro rnas to be
differentially expressed now what is
differential expression it is
the change in the amount of
rna that
translates into protein
under two different groups
so
this sort of a change
usually has a lot of effects
and
those effects are
very fatal sometimes like they can cause
cancer or they can cause other diseases
which are pretty dangerous
but it's not all sad and sorrow
after all and this particular research
deals with
cancer cell lines which are cultured on
earth and then taken to space and
kept in the international space station
interestingly it has been noticed that
when these cancer cell lines are kept
in microgravity
they lose their potential of signaling
they stop signaling between one another
because there's no gravity to keep them
together most probably and they form
this sort of a spheroid which is called
a multicellular spheroid
they start rotating
and they lose their capacity of
signaling and this loss of signaling
potential
stops metastasis metastasis is that
stage of cancer when the cancer starts
to spread from one particular part of
your body for example if you have lung
cancer and metastasis kicks in it starts
spreading all throughout your body but
it has been noticed that microgravity
acts as a boon or a gift and
these cancer cells stop
proliferating and maybe this is the
beginning of something wonderful in the
domain of cancer medicine
and that's why you must have come across
the term space medicine a lot so space
medicine is not only something which
deals with taking care of astronauts and
protecting them from harm but also to
understand and analyze various treatment
technologies and methodologies about the
international space station use this
unique environment of space
and how can that be utilized and brought
back to earth for the better good of
each and every human beings on earth so
this is the reason why we are talking a
lot about space omics space omix is not
only a niche subject but it
has the potential to be
spread all over the world and to benefit
each and every human beings and if this
isn't interesting to you
then i don't know what it is
now
i know
many of you
who are sitting today in the audience
are interested in getting involved in
astrobiology
to get involved with some great
organization to do some internships to
get a start in the career right so
here's a list of certain opportunities
that i'm going to talk about which would
definitely benefit you the first one is
the astrobiology
school which is known as red recon
exobiology for doctor in french or
the exobiology school for
doctors doctorates for phds so this is
an opportunity for phds as well as some
masters student as well who can
participate in the french exobiology
society's course and get involved with
great esa scientists that's european
space agency scientists i had the
opportunity to interact with them
one-on-one and get some vital insights
that's an amazing opportunity
then you also have blue marble space
institute of science which provides
young scientist program as well as
visiting scholar program opportunity
the young scientist program is for
bachelors
and the visiting scholars are for
masters and those who are beyond that
maybe if you are pursuing a phd or
postdoc or you are a faculty or
scientist you can still join bmsis
as an associate research scientist
i will talk about
the criteria and the requirements to get
into it in a while
so you can also get involved in some
analog missions such as esep earth
science exploration program it was done
in ladakh and it is going to be done
over and over again so you would
definitely get the opportunity again
this is done
uh mainly by amity university of mumbai
the amity center of excellence in
astrobiology
then there's a lunaris
analog research station it's a moon
analog where you can spend a lot of time
do some experiments gain vital insights
some results
and the environment the feel is as if
you are on moon you can also get
involved in the european astrobiology
institute lc japan that's earth life
science institute
but more importantly you can also
showcase your projects showcase whatever
you have done and interact with some
great scientists
in conferences so there are a number of
conferences which are held every year
dedicated to astrobiology for example
i've grad e this is a conference for
astrobiology graduates
all over the world
the students can participate whether you
are an undergraduate student or a
graduate student whether you're doing
your phd you can participate here there
are some great keynote lectures by some
great astrobiologists so you can
listen to them get vital insights
interact with them and there's apps icon
which is
hosted by
in collaboration with nasa
and it's a nasa funded conference so
this is going to be held in 2022 as well
so definitely check out apps icon and
appgrady and all of these institutes and
their opportunities now let me tell you
the major requirement to be a
participant in all of these events so
all of these events as you might have
guessed requires you to
be involved in some sort of a project an
astrobiology or a space omix project so
that you
are excited you are interested but you
are going to
attend these
events to do something more right you
are not visiting a
tv show or
maybe some youtube video right you are
going to a conference or
an event so you are expected to do to do
something greater a little bit more than
what you have
done so
doing a project at least starting a
project of your own is the
way to go is the first tip that you
should take
and
here we are find biotic is gonna help
you to get started with your own
astrobiology or spaceonics project
and how and how to do that and what is
the procedure i'll talk in just a while
but before we move on let me give you an
overview of the career path to become an
astrobiologist suggested by nasa
so this is the most authentic data that
you can get right you don't have to
trust my words you can
believe what nasa has to say
but before i talk about this it would be
great if you can head over to the chat
section and
write down the level of education that
you are currently pursuing whether you
are a bachelor student or a master's
student or a phd student or you are
postdoc or you are a scientist
and it would be great if you can also
write down
what's the subject that you're studying
so that i can get an understanding of
what kind of audience i have and
i would show you
that how whatever you are studying
whatever field you belong to
whichever
subject is your you are majoring in
right now
you still have a great chance to become
an astrobiologist and the career path is
pretty straightforward
so i can already see some great
responses i can see
yeah
uh here to your question as well i had a
poll with me which i was supposed to
launch so it would be actually very
great if i just launched a poll and
every uh everyone could just uh vote and
tell us to which different fields they
belong to and also what are their
research interests so this way we will
uh
have
saved the different sorts of fields and
research interests of our participants
so my first question here is
what is your level of education are you
an undergraduate a graduate a
postgraduate or pursuing phd or done
with phd or a postdoc and also what are
your research interests omits
spacesomics infectious diseases or data
science or precision medicine or
bioinformatics using r and python or
machine learning and in the chat box uh
you can feel free to tell about which
particular field or degree you can see
you belong to
over to yoshiboji thank you i'll be just
closing this poll in um
30 more seconds
awesome great thank you sonalika that
was
this is a great way to
learn your responses and understand you
to know you well
so it would be great if you can
go down to the poll and register your
answers
and
later on i would definitely
listen
more to your interests
interact with you answer your questions
at the end of the webinar and
maybe then we can discuss further so i
could see a lot of people who are
currently pursuing undergraduate they
are from biotech they are from pharma
they are from microbiology some are
masters some are phds and postdocs so
here is
your
career path as suggested by nasa so
you are earning a degree right now right
so you are in this particular
domain and nasa says that you can earn a
degree in any field it can be physics
biology
oceanography
geology astronomy
definitely biology also includes medical
science and other sub domains
so
you are earning a degree
at the same time you are also building a
community
talking about the community of
astrobiologists you know since
astrobiology or space biology is still a
very new term
the community size is very small but
it's great to see that the number is
increasing today we have 77 people who
are enthusiastic about astrobiology here
there might be many more attending the
youtube live sessions many more people
who might not be able to have been able
to join because of the time zone
difference but they would definitely get
a recording of the video and so this
community is growing
and this is very important in your
journey
earning your degree and being a part of
a community so that you can interact
with people develop projects work on
them
and
understand how
an astrobiologist works so that's what
nasa says you do your graduate work
you
join various societies clubs or
organizations just like you are today
here at find vertex being one of those
organizations
and you can earn your doctorate that's a
phd degree look for funding
opportunities
and there you are
you are almost there you are
now
having a fruitful career in astrobiology
i would give you a fun statistics today
i went over to linkedin i guess many of
you use linkedin if you don't please
make an account on linkedin and
feel free to connect with all of us and
we can chat and discuss more about space
office there so i've headed over to
linkedin and in the job section i looked
i filtered the search with astrobiology
at the top
and i came across around 20 jobs
available in the domain of astrobiology
in the
last 24 hours i guess which has been
posted so you can see
there's
a growing number of opportunities in the
domain of astrobiology and the people to
grab them are few
so this is your great opportunity
to make yourself available make yourself
aware and
kind of get your hands dirty in this
field so that you would be selected
above others and you can
begin your career in the domain of
astrobiology all right enough said
about career opportunities but
the
main question which comes up is how to
start working with the data that is
generated from the space flight missions
right
what is the mechanism or the methodology
to work with this data well that is
something which
this program is going to talk about and
we are going to hold your hand take you
step by step and
make you understand how to work with
this data
all of the projects all of the research
that we do at find biotech is
done on the server of my biotech which
is called the server t bio info platform
i am going to give you a quick
overview of what this platform looks
like
and how you can work on this platform
right
so
um
if you can see my screen then
i think
now you would be able to see my screen
with the server t by info platform and
i would also
all right thank you navia
so there you go you have the link in the
chat section
so
head over to the link click on the link
go to this particular
page
you might get a prompt to sign up just
sign up using your email id or google
email id and you will get the
credentials to
use this pipeline in some time and
now i would show you what this server
platform is all about so you know the
data that is generated from
any experiment be it a space related
experiment or a much focused biological
experiment
it's huge in its volume there's
big numbers of gigabytes involved so it
is not possible to analyze them
on a personal computer also if you would
like to
use your coding skills it would take 100
hundreds of lines of codes which is not
always a sweet spot for biologists right
so that's where fine biotech server t
buying for platform makes things easier
for you
if you would look on my screen you would
see that there's various
categories in which the server is
divided you would find the ngs data mass
spectroscopy that's related to
proteomics structural biology data
integration and modeling which mainly
deals with machine learning algorithms
virology cancer biology
and a lot under the ngs data you would
see
there's transcriptomics
genomics epigenetics dna rna and
you see a lot of names right
so i'm gonna go ahead and show you how
these
platform works
so if you look at transcriptomics the
first option is an r and you seek and
there's a drop down button if i click on
here you would get some demo pipelines
so let me click on one of the demo
pipeline just to give you an overview
so here's what the platform
looks like and all these names that you
can see here are basically the
algorithms which people use to analyze
the data sets
but to actually use this
uh algorithms in your computer using
code would be a very tedious task
but pine biotech has made it easier for
you how much easy well as easy as just a
point and click
so it's it would just take you
a
click to use these high profile
algorithms to analyze your data and
that's not the end as you can see like
magic there are certain
algorithm names which are highlighted in
yellow so
this platform is ai enabled and it gives
you
a hint as to what would should be your
next algorithm in the process
so in a typical rnseq
pipeline
you have the next generation sequencing
data which is generated by the sequencer
you then do some preprocessing that is
cutting off the unwanted reads you can
see here it shows you how
you just chop it off which are
unnecessary
you also do some cleaning pcr cleaning
which are unwanted
then you go on to the next part which is
alignment
on the genome
then you form some
alternative splicing isoform
construction
to those people who for whom these
terms are pretty unfamiliar and new i
have a secret tool for you and how you
can actually get hold of these terms and
not only that how can you also learn to
use this platform i would
tell you about that in just a second
so once you click on end and you make
like connect all the
required algorithms and a beautiful
visualization here by the way you get
that output since it's a demo pipeline
it generated the output right away but
if it would be a real pipeline which you
would use for your project it would take
a lot of time because it's
very server
loaded thing all right so these are the
various
results that are generated from the
pipeline what each of these means
is might be something which is new to
you but i would give you again
in a while
a trick how to understand that so may i
downloaded this particular file because
this is what i'm interested about
and here you
i have downloaded it you can see
i guess
um
just a second i will share my screen
well so that you can see it
all right so here you can see that the
data which i don't showed you has been
downloaded here
and then i went on
to
load this particular data in
an excel sheet here
so in this excel sheet you can see that
table says that there's group one of
certain samples and there's group two
and
what you can do is you can compare the
various genes and their expressions here
are the gene ids as you might say
so
this is the entire
work or the research that people out
there do but now as i promised i would
show you how you can learn about them
so if you go to the
learn omixlogic platform i'm sure you
would get the link in the chat section
you would get
various options here if you click on
courses
you would see there's various courses
just like sonalica mentioned in the
introduction part right so here's an
introduction to bioinformatics there's
bioinformatics using python and various
other courses like genomics and
transcriptomics if you go down here you
can see various projects guided projects
which you can do just to get warmed up
and here you can also see the various
types of courses available
and once you go through these courses
you would get a better understanding of
what these data types are how to use
them what are the various algorithms
actually talking about
and that would make you ready for
the project
that we usually do on this platform and
you can do as well so i would also take
this opportunity to show you my own
project that i did
in the domain of astrobiology so if you
go to the project section you see here
this is my project
i click on it it says the transcriptomic
analysis of dna damage response in
zebrafish embryos under simulated
microgravity i won't go into much detail
today because i would be doing that step
by step explaining every method and
step that i use to do this project in a
later
session
but to give you an over view what i did
was i investigated what is the effect of
simulated microgravity on zebrafish and
how that affects the dna damage response
and whether the damage that is caused by
microgravity and radiation comparable
similar or different and
that's what my project is you can
definitely check out my project on the
portal itself and read all about it so
if you go here you would also get access
to the data sets
then you can read the abstract
here understand what's the project all
about
and why are we doing this it said in the
introduction section the methods those
who already are familiar with omix and
bioinformatics would definitely
understand the methods that i have used
here some of them are machine learning
algorithms some of them are not that
here's the results that has been
generated from all those
applications and tools and
the final part is how i interpret the
results that has been generated from the
pipelines and make a conclusion about
what i understand
from the data that is generated so
this is all about um the projects that
you can do here at pine biotech's
uh server platform and
as you might have understood by now that
it is pretty much important to do to do
that to get your hands dirty to start
working on your own project right
because
that gives you an upper hand that gives
you an edge and that helps you to get
selected
in all those
opportunities so
here i would like to give you a small
overview of the program that we are
going to launch it would be a one month
program and it's divided into four parts
you can say
so first there would be interactive
sessions they would be usually one hour
live sessions with q a
they would be held on zooms on just like
today and there would be recorded
sessions available for those who
register and book their seats as well
and after you have done that
this is for the first time that i am
letting the cat out out of the bag that
there would be
a guest
special lecture by a guest faculty and
that person is an expert in this domain
he has he or she has been working in the
domain of space omix for quite a long
time and it's always a good idea to
learn from the best in the business so
stay tuned register yourself to get to
know who that special guest lecturer
would be and i am looking forward to
this session
pretty much
after you have done that after you've
gone through other courses after you
have attended the lectures you would get
an opportunity to start working on your
own project definitely you would get a
mentor support and
that would definitely be an amazing
thing which i'm looking forward to
because working on a project doing some
hands-on is the best thing that you can
do
for enhancing your education or
that's what i call as proper learning
and finally when you have done that you
have completed it congratulations you
have
gone through this hustle and finally
earned
your certificate you would get a
certified you would get certified by
fine biotic
and that would be a an amazing feather
to your hat added
so finally i would like to give you a
small overview of the one month program
and what we have in store for you the
first day would be an introduction to
astrobiology talking about what this
term means talking about origin of life
on earth the various extremophiles
we would also touch upon the debate of
rna world versus d in the world the tree
of life and it would be on 19th of
october
on 25th of october we would
talk much more focused on origin of life
and evolution we would
talk about the great in endosyme biases
theory we would show you how you can
work with data sets where you can find
those data sets and we would also give
talk to you about some project examples
of reconstructing ancient rna or ancient
protein using machine learning there has
been a lot of work which has been done
on a very popular protein which is
called rubisco to recreate it
reconstruct it understand how it evolved
and that gives us a better picture of
origin of life
then on first of november we would talk
specifically about space on mix and
astronaut health again taking the
reference of the nasa twin study digging
in deeper understanding the various
environmental factors understanding the
various results of this study
and it's i will also show you how you
can
retrieve the data and get ready for your
project
and
on the 8th of november
there will be one session which would
talk more about
the various omics types which are
required for space omics and astronaut
health
like genomics proteomics transcriptomics
metagenomics in general so that you have
a better picture of what we are dealing
with
and finally
on the 15th of november we would focus
on a case study of
a few projects including mine so i would
give you an overview step-by-step
analysis of my projects the methods that
i used and the results and how to
interpret them
so
that's all that i had for you today i
hope that you
got some insights into what we are
dealing with and why we are so much
hyped up about this particular field of
space science
and i hope that you liked the fact that
we are going to provide you
an opportunity to do your own project
so that you stand out from the crowd
so
i think that's all that i had for you
today but i will transfer the stage to
sonalika who would give you an overview
and a brief understanding of how you can
register and be a part of this program
and the other details
and also if you
have any questions
regarding space omix or